if it is not possible to converge closer
people disperse further
life all the time distracts our
attention
and we do not even have time to notice
from what exactly
it's like a key to unknown chambers
within the castle of one's home
there are two cardinal sins from which
all others spring
and laziness
youth is happy because it has the
capacity to see beauty
anyone who keeps the ability to see
beauty
never grows old
first impressions are always unreliable
through the paradise of Vice you reach
the hell of virtue
the meaning of life is that it stops
only people Afflicted with the same
disease understand each other
all language is but a poor translation
are a narcotic
the first sign of the beginning of
knowledge is the desire to die
by believing passionately in something
that still does not exist we create it
existence in if whatever we have not
sufficiently desired
it is not difficult to love the ones who
leave
I think we ought to read only the kind
of books
and wound and stab us
paths are made by walking
since it couldn't get any worse
it got better
I have the true feeling of myself only
when I am unbearably unhappy
faith is the acts of the
Justice heavy
just as light
he is terribly afraid of dying because
he hasn't yet lived
most of gaiety
much sadder than openly expressed
sadness
with a real enemy boundless courage is
instilled in you
and man struggle against the world
bet on the world
a thought expressed aloud immediately
and completely
loses its meaning
written down it also always loses it
but sometimes it acquires a new meaning
it is much easier to oppress your
neighbor if you know nothing about him
conscience then does not torment
women are traps which lie and wait for
men everywhere
in order to drag them down into the
finite
don't waste time looking for obstacles
they may not exist
kindness is in a sense
desolate
when a woman shares her problems with
you most likely she does not complain
trusts you
the older a person gets the more his
Horizons expand
and life opportunities are getting
smaller and smaller
they lie the least when they lie the
least
not when they have the least reason to
lie
don't marry the one you love
but marry the one who loves you
one of the most effective Temptations of
evil is the call to fight
anyone looking for evidence of
infidelity hopes not to find it
the more you trust a person the more he
is seducing you
what we call evil is only an
inevitability in Our Endless development
the spirit becomes free only when it
ceases to be a support
from a certain point onward there is no
longer any turning back
is the point that must be reached
what is possible and tolerable for the
four of us is impossible and intolerable
for this fifth
besides there are four of us and we
don't want five of us
just think how many thoughts the blanket
Smothers while one lies alone in bed
how many unhappy dreams it keeps warm
the truth path goes along a rope that is
not stretched high but above the Earth
itself
it seems to be designed more to be
tripped over than to be walked on
path from the head to the pen is much
longer and more difficult than the path
from the head to the
everything including lies serves the
truth
there is often a painful discrepancy
between world view and reality
man has long refused to participate in
the creation of the world and
responsibility for it
the book should be an ice pick for the
Frozen sea within us
theoretically there is the fullest
possibility of happiness
to believe in something indestructible
in oneself and not strive for it
only people affected by the same ailment
understand each other
nobody can give more than the one who
has lost everything
he who has cognized the fullness of life
does not know the fear of death
fear of death is only the result of an
unfulfilled life
there is no need to leave the house
stay at your desk and listen
don't even listen wait don't even wait
be still and alone
and the world will open to you
it cannot otherwise
pay no attention to anyone do what you
think is right
it is impossible to make excuses when
they do not want to believe you
thoughts that are spoken out loud
immediately and finally lose their
meaning
we have collected these quotes from
France Kafka who possesses the Exquisite
Talent for fusing elements of realism
and the Fantastic you need to have a
sufficiently Savvy mind and life
experience to fully understand the
meaning and a real sense of his
statements thanks for watching